a beautiful csgo skin is like a death
dealing piece of
art it's a confidence booster something
that makes that 3k
clutch just a little bit sweeter but
these skins can be hard to find easily
ripped off and
obviously incredibly expensive
just ask our resident skin addict dmitry
oh
ayah i ball out and recently one of
these rare skins
was sold for 150 thousand
dollars potentially making it the most
expensive skin
ever sold in the history of
[Music]
counter-strike
hit all the buttons the like button the
subscribe to the channel button the
notification bell
that way you never miss new videos ever
again and if there's a story that you
want to see us cover here on don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com so on
may 4th
it was revealed that a danish cisco skin
collector who goes by luxus bums on
twitter
purchased this skin for a whopping 150
000 now we're going to break down what
makes this
ak worth so much money but first
a tiny bit of history valve introduced
the concept of skins to cs go back in
2013 with the arms deal
update and fans of the game have been
obsessed with
skins ever since and it's safe to say
that the arms deal
update impacted cs go's economy on a
fundamental level
see now you could basically gamble by
opening
cases with the tiny chance of winning
something
indescribably rare and very expensive
this led to the steam marketplace and
that eventually led to a bunch of
shadier third-party websites where you
could buy
sell and trade your skins all of this
created a tradition of streamers and
pro players opening looking at and
freaking out
over rare skins on streaming
[Music]
you know i opened tonight before in
these yeah
then in 2014 valve introduced the first
ever sticker capsule for the katowice a
major
katavitse wasn't the first major for cs
go that was dreamhack winter in 2013
but katowice was the first time you
could buy
stickers for a specific tournament and
here's where that 150
000 ak comes in the four stickers on
that ak that homie
purchased are referred to as titan
hollows and they're the second most
sought after
sticker that came from that 2014
kaidobitse sticker capsule
the most sought after stickers are the
eyebuy power hollows and don't worry
we'll talk about those
in just a second in 2014 these titan
hollows and the sticker capsule were
pretty cheap and
people were buying them for pennies on
the dollar but over the years as more
and more people gravitated to cs go and
a new fan base wanted skins and stickers
the consensus came to be that the
katowice hollows were cleanest
especially the titans because like all
things collectible
the old [ __ ] is the most expensive add
in the fact that titan were a dominant
team with sick players like a young
kenny s
and there you go all of a sudden you
have an expensive
and rare sticker now on to the skin
itself
the 661 stat track case hardened
often referred to as a blue gem there's
a lot
to this thing case hardened skins by
themselves aren't
that rare but ones with the so-called
blue gem
pattern especially the ones with the
blue gem pattern
all along the top those are incredibly
sought after
a case hardened with a blue splotch here
or there
nobody really cares about those but 661
with the blue
pattern beautifully positioned along the
top of the ak in a line
this is considered the goat of blue gem
skins
and therefore is extremely expensive
this is the this is the best pattern in
the game
this one that non-star trek is like 700
keys
[Music]
now you add in four of those rare ice
blue
titan hollow stickers to that freshest
stat track case hardened blue gem oh
baby you have a sticker skin combination
worth
to our danish friend anyway 150
thousand dollars but we're not done
because the same guy that bought that
crazy ak
bought an m4 house skin with four i buy
power holo stickers slapped onto the
side of it
for a hundred and twenty two thousand
dollars
here's the deal with that one howl is
considered a
contraband skin meaning you can't buy a
new one
ever valve banned the skin due to its
crazy backstory and
that's something that we've covered on a
recent episode of our short series
but then just a few weeks later
something strange happened
not even a month after the howl came out
valve was slapped with a dmca takedown
notice from a deviantart user named
canis albus
the young finnish artist posted the
following to their blog
looking familiar someone has stolen one
of my artworks to make a custom skin for
a gun in a game called counter-strike
global offensive
so the howl is expensive to begin with
because the original artwork was stolen
valve had to essentially reskin the damn
thing then they
banned it meaning you can only get one
second hand from a collector
or a marketplace like buff 163 now the
eye by power stickers
a single sticker is so rare because of
the match fixing scandal involving the
ibuypower roster
that happened back in 2014. we've
covered that story a million times
before
cs go's 2015 match fixing scandal is one
of the biggest scandals in the game's
history
four of north america's strongest
players were banned overnight
cutting their pro career short so of
course because of the controversy
everyone wants one of these stickers on
top of that because there's a dwindling
supply of the katavitse sticker capsules
out in the wild
these stickers are becoming more and
more
rare how rare are we talking a single
i buy power holo sticker is worth
roughly
25 000 to the right buyer
so take a banned skin that you can't get
anymore add in
four stickers worth 25 grand each and
yeah
you easily have a sticker skin
combination worth a hundred
grand but what's even crazier about this
howl purchase
is that this danish collector did it on
the open market
see once you start getting into skins
that are worth ten
twenty thirty thousand dollars these
sales usually happen
privately and these private sales
usually involve an intermediary a guy
like our boy zipple
whose whole gig is working with buyers
and sellers
to make sure that everyone is getting a
fair deal i don't want to like
say that i'm i'm the best person in the
world and i do it you know to help the
unboxing it's also actually just
because i fully enjoy stopping people
from
from profiting on on like things that i
i perceive as like morally wrong but
that's not what happened with the howl
skin
see it was purchased straight from buff
163
a reputable chinese marketplace that
also happens to be the biggest in the
world
it's like walking into a ferrari
dealership telling the sales guy to go
himself and then buying the first car
you see in the show floor without a test
drive
at ticket price nobody does either of
these things
and by the way zipple says that that m4
howl sale
is the single largest sale on the site
ever that's nuts now i know that 150
grand
sounds like an incredible amount of
money to drop on something
even as rare as these two skins but if
you've been paying attention to the cs
go skins market over the last 18 months
this ridiculous price actually kind of
makes sense
because by 2019 the skins market
shifted or more specifically the skins
market [ __ ]
exploded it's something that youtubers
like jesus
talked about while it was happening the
prices of csgo cases
have been going insane recently
investors have been making a fortune
prices are eating record levels and this
is all despite the fact that it feels
like we're living
in the end times at the moment there's a
few different reasons why the skins
market went nuts
for one cs go hit its highest ever
player base in april of 2020 with 1.3
million players
so possibly more people than ever
interested in buying skins
two you had the emergence of china who
gained access to csgo around the same
time
and it turns out that that region had a
lot of people looking for skins
and a lot of people with a ton of money
to blow so now as the price of these
skins are driven up by
people to whom money is no concern
spending thousands at a time
now these skins become legitimate
investments and collectors start holding
on to them as collectors hold on to
already incredibly rare and hard to find
skins
the demand skyrockets and therefore so
does the price
which is how you end up with someone
dropping 150 grand
on that case hardened stat track ak that
we talked about earlier we've covered
the situation with the cs go skins
market
on this channel before the world of
buying selling and unboxing
cs go skins is often an exciting place
the other side effect of this exploding
skins market is that it's created an
entirely new
job ecosystem for people who know what
they're doing
for example let's say a friend
introduces you to
and gets you hooked on counter-strike
naturally you want to buy some dope-ass
skins
so let's say you set aside three
thousand dollars to do so
but three grand is a lot of money you
have no idea what you're doing and after
hearing horror stories of people getting
scammed out of their skins
you're a little unsure of what to do
next this is where someone like zipple
enters the picture
a guy with an incredible amount of
knowledge about the skin
scene who acts as an intermediary
between buyer and seller
and make sure that you're not getting
ripped off when you go to buy a skin
zipple and others like him help buyers
find the right skin for the right price
often talking to the seller on the
buyer's behalf
at the same time they work with the
seller to make sure that they get a fair
price for the skin that they're selling
he often does inventory appraisals on
stream while also buying and selling
skins and helping his chat understand
the market better he was also in the
replies to that thread about the 150
000 spent on that ak that we talked
about now these huge cs go skin
purchases
coincide with a very similar phenomenon
the recent
unprecedented growth of the trading card
collectible markets
you know sports cards pokemon cards
magic the gathering you get it investors
have been flocking to collectibles for
whatever reason and the prices have
skyrocketed according to a report on the
state of trading cards published by ebay
the site saw 142 increase in trading
cards
with global growth capping out at 162
what that actually looks like is a tom
brady rookie card selling for 555
988 now when it comes to pokemon cards
ebay says they saw an increased sales
amount of 574 percent from 2019
to 2020. what that looks like is a 1999
pokemon base set
first edition shadowless hollow
charizard
selling for 295 300
a very famous magic the gathering card
sold for five hundred and eleven
thousand one hundred dollars naturally
people on twitch have
jumped at the opportunity to open
randomly expensive cards on stream
creating quite the trend
[Music]
yes yes yes
that's like a 20 000 card
voltorb i love that guy too he's gonna
be hiding
oh let's go let's go
oh my god
oh my god it's hollow
it's all this trading card craze has
gotten so out of hand
that when [ __ ] mcdonald's released a
25th anniversary promo set of pokemon
cards
scalpers snatched them up and in certain
cases
sold them for a thousand dollars on ebay
i really wish
i didn't chew on a bunch of my pokemon
cards when i was a kid
probably wouldn't be sitting here right
now
gonna wait for the dog to finish
drinking
water
everyone wants one of these i buy power
stickers on top of that
okay she's still drinking her water